تعهدات الغربيه بارسال مساعدات عسكريه
لاوكرانيا مستمره اخرها دول حلف الناتو
التي وعدت بارسال المزيد من الذخيره لدعم
اوكرانيا باستعاده اراضيها من الروس
ما هي اكثر الدول المانحه للمساعدات
العسكريه لاوكرانيا امريكا سته
مليار دولار بريطانيا
5.1 مليار دولار الاتحاد الاوروبي
3.3 مليار دولار بولندا 2.5 مليار دولار
المانيا
2.5 مليار دولار كندا
1.4 مليار دولار اما عن انواع المعدات
العسكريه المقدمه من الدول المانحه
لاوكرانيا فهي عباره عن 31 دبابه ابرامز
مقدمه من امريكا والتي وصفها الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن بانها اكثر الدبابات
قدره في العالم ونظام صواريخ المدفعيه
عاليه الحركه هاي مارس 59 مركبه قتاليه من
طراز برادلي وانظمه للدفاع الجوي بالاضافه
الى مدافع اما بريطانيا فقدمت لاوكر
عشره دبابه تشالنجر 2 وانظمه الدفاع جوي
تتضمن ستار ستريك والمانيا في المقابل
اعطت كيف اربع عشره دبابه ليوبار 2 وانظمه
الدفاع جوي تتضمن
واخيرا بولندا اكثر من 200 دبابه
لاوكرانيا لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات